[Music]
hello everybody welcome my name is
Sandra cool I'm a product manager at
Google cloud and here with me is Vic
Ignatius his a cloud solution to
architect so today we're going to be
talking about secures our supply chain
on Google for your kubernetes workload
here is the agenda for this talk we're
gonna start with overview of container
security and how supply chain security
fits in the bigger picture then we'll
talk about how supply chain security
often looks like the common pitfalls and
we're going to go over a few best
practices to help you navigate the space
then we're going to go into introduce a
few GCP products that's going to help
you secure your supply chain in the end
Vic's are gonna show us a demo of how
the different products and best practice
is tied together let's get started so
how is securing a container different
from securing a VM let's go over a few
areas first surface of TAC containers
packaged all the dependencies and
application needs into a nice little
package so that you don't need as many
dependencies libraries processes running
on the host image to support the
containerized applications this way
you're able to minimize the host OS and
reduce your attack surface they're
resource isolation containers has that
built in as well it uses namespaces and
C groups to allocate resources for
particular resources such as a storage
volume to you know a containerized
application or process for permissions
just like VMs you want to configure
fine-grained permissions with content
based applications as well but one big
difference there is containers encourage
micro services so instead of running one
giant monolith
that has access to everything now it's
much easier to have smaller applications
having smaller access scope as well so
it's much easier to implement a
fine-grained access control and then
last but not least life cycle this is
probably the biggest difference between
containerized applications and VM based
applications with containers it's
immutable it incurs fast deployment
it's very developer friendly and always
the applications getting released daily
versus in the VM based world often hands
a monolithic application doesn't get
updated for a few months
so with this and you have with micro
services you have a lot more services to
keep track of in the production
environment a lot more deployment to
keep track of in the production
development a lot of people adopt a
continuous integration and deployment
model to continue pushing out new
changes you know just over time so for a
lot of organizations the last piece the
life cycle piece is where most changes
needs to happen to the infrastructure
because now you have continuous
deployment you have to streamline your
security checks and so that's going to
be the area of today's focus for this
talk we're going to share a few tools
lessons container characteristics to
help you navigate this migration to
container based application lifecycle
management so containers has a few
characteristics that is going to enable
you to have a different security mindset
and implement a different types of
security model that leads to better
security in the long run let's go let's
go through them first containers are
short-lived and frequently redeployed
this means that you can have one
centralized processes that apply changes
to your production workload and there's
be less need for direct access to
running applications to make clean
on-the-fly changes because making a
change through a centralized pipeline
as simple as click of a button so you
would be able to minimize ad hoc changes
and have a unified process for apply
changes to the production environment
containers are also immutable so instead
of making one line changes to a
containerized application you suppose to
the intention is to make changes to the
container as a whole you change one line
of code you click a button and it
reviews the entire thing and redeploys
to production environment now you have a
something brand-new running and the
kubernetes infrastructure allows
deployment that causes minimum
interruption so you're able to come
apply changes continuously you know no
more such Saturday 2:00 a.m. update when
there was necessary anymore
containers also enables fast paced
development this is oftentimes the
biggest true to the container format is
that developers are able to test out and
push out new changes superfast as the
security stakeholders and compliance
stakeholders now every release takes
days to complete a versus a used to take
you know months to complete so we cannot
afford to scrutinize every release
anymore take weeks to examine every
components of each release this means
that streamlines security controls are
now necessary it needs to be baked into
the automated release process is that in
your csv pipeline as I guess applied on
the fly so that the developers don't
have to slow down and wait for the
security checks to happen before new
changes get applied into production the
good news is the container format is
declarative and expectable it means that
you don't have to run the containers in
order to examine the content of it it
allows you to have more visibility into
the content of a container before you
deploy it before you run it it also
means that you can have much better
automation on your security controls and
scan
to ultimate those type of checks as part
of your CD pipeline um how are the we
have hear from a number of users that
taking care of container security can be
manual for most container users that we
talked to they have adopted continuous
integration continuous deployment
because it is so developer friendly you
apply to new super quickly but a lot of
them is still stuck in the old security
model where deploy controls are applied
manually um you know we have
stakeholders basically manually making
sure that every release has met all the
necessary requirement it's also ad hoc
the old habit is hard to break and we
also see that admins and developers
accessing running containers directly
and making changes on the fly and this
opens doors to chat to changes that are
not tracked in a centralized process and
you have you have running hold that is
that diverts from its original deploy
States and you can't you know explain or
track that using your centralized
processing pipeline and those kind of
changes happen at the end of release
it's a more reactive model instead of a
preventative model so instead of
controlling what gets into production by
making those ad hoc manual changes now
you're reacting to bad things are
happening in the production environment
in a very manual way so um as I
mentioned having a CI CV pipeline does
not stop untrusted code from being
deployed right you can have a sensitive
pipeline has scans and analysis and a
board and all goodness but you can have
a privileged attacker it could be a
developer who's making a mistake it
could also be a compromised account that
is able to deploy code directly to
production and now this person is
bypassing all the checks that you have
you no longer have
total control what goes into production
environment and on top of that if you
don't lock down your production
environment you have admins and
developers and privilege personnel
having direct access to the running jobs
and now you have another vector of on
track changes to your production
environment and even for those who have
a lock down have a centralized CA CD
there are many common pitfalls that
could happen you know in the developer
phase people could make a mistake they
could check in code that contains
vulnerabilities and their con can be
fished and there could be a malicious
insider during the CI CD phase if you
have a one monolithic super privileged
robot account that's running the entire
end-to-end say sed process you may
experience a confused deputy problem
your ah csv pipeline may have a bug in
the testing phase and get tricked into
you know reading your source data and
pushing random images to your image
repository there could be privilege
escalations there in the pipeline itself
and in the deploy stage you could also
have trusted account that is able to
bypassing the C sed checks you know
having a CCD again does not prevent
deploying untrusted code so what to do
we'll have a few best practices here
hopefully the help can help you navigate
around those common pitfalls first you
should have a centralized lockdown say
ICD process as a single choke point for
applying changes to your production
environment you should build images from
only trusted sources and you should also
have streamlined streamlined scanning
and analysis for images last but not
least explicitly verify each of the
images that you deploy to a production
environment and have that baking as part
of your CI CD process I'm going to go
through each of the best practices
look into details of what exactly a
requires so first having a centralized
lockdown CIC V pipeline it is very um
beneficial to have a single process that
every changes to your production have to
go through it makes it easier to track
changes it makes it easier to explain
who your stakeholders what are the
criteria for production release is we
also encourage that you should implement
this privilege for each of the release
step for example the CI portion of the
pipeline should have a different
permission from the CD portion of the
pipeline so that at the stage that is
able to deploy code to your production
environment shouldn't have also have
permission to check in code for example
to your repository or read your source
code or checking your source code don't
blindly trust your image repository just
because the image is kept in to your
production repository that's not meaning
that it can be safely deployed your
production environment it could contain
vulnerabilities
it could be outdated it could be from
something from a year ago you really
want to verify every images you deploy
to a production explicitly at a time of
the deployment
you should also minimize ad hoc accesses
to running containers so there's no good
having a centralized process if people
can access the running jobs directly you
want you need to lock down the entire
process there are also a few recommended
practices that I wouldn't go into
details such as in having metadata that
you can examine later and you know just
means that is automated does not mean
that human should not be involved it's
always good to have human text as part
of your CI CD pipeline next lesson
buuuut images from trusted sources so we
know that um we look at our food we're
like is this organic is this FDA
approved similarly when you build your
container you want to make sure you you
minimum secure be images so that you
minimize your attack surface from the
beginning you want to whitelist
only trusted code from your repositories
or trusted third-party repositories so
that you don't have random images
downloaded from the internet making
their way into your production job you
should also be explicit in your step in
your talker file which means that use
explicit version - not just tags the
explicit version of with scripting so
when you run a darker Bude two days from
now it would produce the same thing when
you have a problem and you're able to go
back and examine exactly what was pulled
into a container so to help with that
best practice google has a managed base
image product it has it's available in a
number of common distributions such as
Debian Ubuntu Santos has hosted on cloud
marketplace these base images are
maintained by Google used by Google
internally on a number of our
infrastructures and products so keep
them up to date we apply vulnerability
scanning to them constantly whenever
there is available fixes we apply the
latest patch so if you have continuous
integration new images get Bute of using
one of the managed secure base images
you would always pull the most recent
up-to-date base images as managed by us
it's a very calming anyway and a low
effort way to start from a clean slate
on your boots I'd lesson number three
streamline tests and analysis so as I
mentioned earlier having a say ICD is
great but it's better if you have
scannings or weddings or testings
baked into that so that only codes that
have passed those criterias makes their
way into production so simple things to
do are enable image vulnerability
scanning and have automated integration
test stages your CSV pipeline and it's
always good
have a QA sign of which could be a human
involved step or it could be a manual
integration gatekeeper and there also
some open source software's that we
provide to help you implement additional
structured tests or image DIF to further
validate images in your CSS pipeline so
to help with this lesson we have a
container registry vulnerability
scanning product that is available today
in beta what it does is every time so
you when you enable this feature it
looks at every single image that you
check into your container registry to
look for no vulnerabilities in a number
of common base images Debian ALP and
Ubuntu a constantly contacting this
industry standard vulnerability database
to pose and most recent Varner abilities
are used for analysis so every time
there is a new vulnerability becomes
available it will be taking into
consideration for the scans that the
product performs on your images in the
repository a also plugs into your
existing Putin so it publishes a result
and then you can use the result for a
number of purposes you can use it to
apply deploy time or policies for
example the only deploy things that
needs a certain vulnerability
requirement you could use it for human
knowledge gathering if you have a
problem and you would like to know what
are the vulnerabilities in your own jobs
you could you know go back and take a
look at all the scanning results last
lesson in force image deployment policy
so that's what I mentioned earlier don't
blindly trust your production image
repository instead verify every image at
a time of deployment so a couple things
to ensure here is making sure that you
would deploy images that actually built
by you you don't have a developer
downloading a bit miner job from the
internet directly and
and and deploy it your production
environment for example and many of us
run third-party images so you want to
make sure you have a explicit whitelist
for the third-party images that is
allowed on your production
infrastructure deploy using digest
instead attacks because digests are
content addressable and you may be able
to run it it doesn't have the risk to
run into race conditions such as the tag
gets updated halfway through a
deployment rollout it also makes it easy
to examine what happened later on you
deployed something you want to go back
and see exactly what happened um type
deployments and digest makes it much
easier we also recommend that you have
deploy policies on a per production
environment basis to maximize your
flexibility so you want to have security
controls for your production environment
you may have very strict rules there
that says not only deploy things that is
vulnerability free only deploy things
that has QA sign off but if you're dead
clusters or if you're staging clusters
you may have more lenient policies as
long as it's beautifui I'm okay to
deploy so it's good to have those type
of policies be declared as the runtime
environment level it's also very
convenient to demonstrate security
controls to stakeholders or potentially
like comfortable compliance officers to
explain to them here are the quite
serious to apply to each of my
environment and we want to demonstrate
to you in one place in a policy it's
okay to allow human to break this
process when there is emergencies but
the trick there is to always log there
is a structure and if humans wants to
deploy a quick fix because things are on
fire and you know we already don't have
time to run through the entire pipeline
fine but log that and so that you can
review that later also for vendor images
we recommend that you deploy those
directly from cloud marketplace
so you know those are authentic
images images coming directly from the
vendor so for this lesson we have a
binary authorization product that will
help with it it's also currently in beta
on GC T so what binary authorization
does is it integrates with different
stages in your CI CD pipeline so as an
image passes through each of the stage
it records a signature signifying that
the image has passed that particular
stage and by the time the image gets to
be deployed to production final
authorization is integrated to the gke
deployment api to check that does this
image have all the required signatures
that customer has set in the policy so
this way even if you have a privileged
individual Telia trying to bypass your
pipeline even though that he has a
permission to deploy to your production
environment he will not be able to
because the code that he's deploying
does not has the right the necessary
signature on it and any failed attempt
to deploy to a binary solution enabled
cluster gets auto logged so you can
review all the events later on in
addition to the signature verification
we also support explicit whitelisting so
your security admin can maintain a
centralized cert party image whitelist
test says you know I only trust this
version of an entry acts only trusted
this version of of a Ruby on Rails and
if you have a developer's is trying to
either accidentally or you know
maliciously deploy something that is
older outdated or has vulnerability he
would not be able to because it's again
it's not explicitly whitelisted so I
told you about four best practices and a
few products to help with respects
practice best practice so here is all it
all tied together you have one
centralized pipeline and you can use a
secure
minimum base image that feed into your
centralized builder once your image gets
checked into the repository it gets
automatically scanned
and then a gets deployed subject to a
deploy policy that you control if you
pass the deploy policy great
it's a trusted imagery goes to
production if not untrusted image gets
locked into order log and for future
review and here are the three features
on TCP that I told you about that are
available for usage now we'll have a
google managed secure minimal base image
that gets updated continuously that you
can just directly pull that into your
pewter we have a vulnerability scanning
that's baked into the google container
registry that happens automatically for
every image you're checking we have a
binary authorization that enforces
deploy policy to your runtime
environment to make sure that only
images you trust get going in there and
now Vic will show you how the different
pieces tie together in action all right
let's give it up for Sandra for dropping
some knowledge right there if we could
switch over to alright so I'm going to
demo a lot of what Sandra talked about
as far as best practices through a CI CD
pipeline with a sample application in my
case I have a front end and a back end
service that I'm gonna deploy
independently into kubernetes and it's
gonna go through this pipeline very
similar to what Sandra just showed so
we're gonna have a developer environment
then we're gonna commit some code that's
gonna be picked up by CI we're gonna
create some images and some kubernetes
manifests that are then gonna be
deployed by spinnaker which is our
continuous deployment tool you'll notice
we have two different tools one and two
different identities for our CI and CD
here number one centrales log Dom she's
got all the policies she told me how to
build this thing so then we're gonna
deploy into staging and then have an
approval and go into production so as
far as the logical view of this CI CD
pipeline where we're gonna bake in some
checks is to make sure you know after we
trigger our commit that we pass unit
tests so we don't want any code going
into production that hasn't passed unit
tests so this is where we're gonna add
one of those checkpoints that the binary
authorization API lets lets us add and
we're gonna add that for passing unit
tests once it's passed unit
we're gonna build our container image
push it to container the container
registry and in there it's automatically
gonna kick off a vulnerability scan the
next thing we're gonna do is add a
attestation or one of these signatures
that says that there were no critical
vulnerabilities in that image once
that's been detected by spinnaker it's
going to deploy it to staging and we're
gonna add another signature there
another attestation that says that we've
actually passed through the staging
process and somebody has clicked this is
good to go
and then we're gonna go ahead and deploy
into production through this demo we're
also going to try to bypass our security
in two ways one is by committing some
vulnerable code as a developer this can
happen to anybody and then the other one
is having our credentials fish too maybe
through some social engineering or
something like that or just you left
your laptop open and someone can can
access your credentials we're gonna try
to deploy directly into our production
cluster we'll see what that looks like
all right so I have a cloud shell here I
have my source code available it's it's
a going app like I said before it's got
a back end and the front end and I'm
just gonna run a command called scaffold
dev and that's gonna actually build my
container push it to the registry and
then deploy my manifest into my GK
cluster that I'm using for development
so here I can see that scaffold has
deployed it's actually doing some port
forwarding for me so I should be able to
access it directly from here cool so
this is my development version we're
gonna try to walk through the happy path
of this the icd pipeline so let's say
that I'm a developer and I want to
change you know from blue to green
because some product manager decided
that green is in right now and so what
we're gonna notice down here is scaffold
has detected that I've changed my source
code and it's gonna do that loop again
it's gonna rebuild my code it's gonna
push it out an image and then redeploy
into my development kubernetes cluster
that's just completed I know it's gonna
do the port forwarding again and we
should be able to see our changes show
up shortly inside of our dev environment
there we go there we go great so green
green looks great
let's go ahead and commit this code
make it green and push it and the soon
as I push it it's gonna be detected by
our CI system in this case we're using
cloud build which is going to detect a
git commit let's go ahead and see if
that's started great so it detected a
change to my back-end image and it
started the process and here what it's
going to do is first build the the
container image it's going to have it
locally and then we're gonna start tests
and as we're testing it it's going to
push that image up to our container
registry when it gets into the container
registry it's automatically going to
kick off a vulnerability scan and in
that meantime we're also gonna add our
attestation our signature that says we
have passed unit tests if we've gone
through these phases so we can see here
the build has completed or is about to
and then we're gonna go ahead and push
that image
well that's happening we can go ahead
and check out what our binary
authorization policies look like
standard you know talked about having
policies centralized for various
projects and clusters so here I can
define my policy if we go into the Edit
pane here we can see that by default in
this project I allow all images but then
I have cluster specific rules that I can
add another thing that I can do is have
a dry run mode where I add a pretty
enforcing policy but I don't actually
reject them I just log into into
stackdriver logging so for my production
cluster I have a specific rule here and
that's going to say that I have to have
these signatures these at two stations
added into my image before it can be
deployed into this cluster and that is
my production cluster so I have to make
sure that I have my unit test passed my
vulnerabilities are checked and there
are no critical ones and that I've
passed through the staging manual
operation so that's my my kind of
default policy I can also add exemptions
and one of the exemptions I can do is
say anything that's provided by Google
is part of us running your gke clusters
for example we're just gonna allow and
that's you know this list of images here
but I also added one for a thing that I
added to my cluster in this case I added
calico and I
want to make sure that calico can run
inside that cluster so I whitelisted
that particular path for images let's go
ahead and take a look okay so so CI has
passed and now we should be able to go
back and check our images oops there we
go so here's my back end image alright
so it just passed upload that image and
ran the scan and there was no
vulnerabilities found in here spinnaker
has picked up that that image was
created there it was was pushed and it
started to check that owner ability scan
result and this is where you can start
to in automation interpret the results
of a vulnerability scan it's not
necessarily the case that every CVE
is a problem for your CI CV process or
for your particular application so you
might whitelist some things or things
like that in my case what I do is I set
a threshold for the CBS s score that is
given to each CVE that's in an image and
if there are any that are above five I
make sure to block the pipeline from
running and we'll see that in a little
bit now that my vulnerability check has
passed and I have no vulnerabilities
that are over my threshold which was
five it should be deploying into staging
and I should see staging is now rolling
out with the green version as the
release manager and only person frankly
running this pipeline I can go ahead and
see that I've got my manual judgment
here and it gives me links to maybe my
metrics dashboard I'm gonna check on you
know some key metrics that I need to
check for performance for example the
latency of the application I can view
that the sites for first staging in
production but I'm just gonna hit
continue because I've already checked
that staging looked good and it had the
green and then that's going to add
another attestation that I've actually
asserted that this this pipeline can
move forward with that we should have
production showing up with green shortly
now I wanted to show what would happen
if I checked in a vulnerability as a
developer so let's say that you know in
my docker file I'm using Alpine which is
a pretty minimal image and that's pretty
awesome
but I find that I need
need some new library or something that
is not available in the Alpine image so
I want to switch to bloom - and I have
an abuti docker file that I create I'm
using a boon to 1804 it seems like a
reasonable thing to do and I just
changed that here to use the Ubuntu one
so now I want to use that Ubuntu docker
file I've got my change here and I'm
going to use that open - and push it
back through my pipeline all right
and as I push that we'll see the same
kind of flow kick off and we'll notice
one main difference when we're checking
the vulnerability so again if I go back
here I should see that cloud build has
started and it's going to build my image
and then we'll see how spinnaker reacts
differently to that the other type of
compromise that I wanted to show you and
how we would block that in our in our
cluster is if my credentials are fished
and I just want you know - someone wants
to maybe launch a shell into my
production cluster so let's say I go to
my production cluster and I check out
what pods I have which I have access to
do I have my front end and back end pods
in there but I want to run just a shell
using Ubuntu so I say image boon - 1604
great and I'm the hacker man so I'm
gonna call it hacker man I just want to
get a shell into this cluster and poke
around a little bit so we see here that
the deployment was actually created so
that might be unexpected for some folks
that are familiar with with kubernetes
as we refresh here and see the workloads
that are in our production cluster you
can see here that hacker man was
actually not allowed well while the
deployment was created it was actually
prevented from creating any pods because
it does not have those at the stations
that we defined in our policy so now
we've subverted that the production
cluster attack by ensuring that we have
our policy set properly in our
let's go check in on our cloud build
setup here looks like things are still
building and pushing once that's
complete we should see it show up in our
vulnerability scans here I'll just go
back and check the images
well that image is finishing pushing out
we're gonna actually look at what hat
what we can see inside of stackdriver
logging about that event of a user
actually trying to hack into our cluster
so in here I should shortly see that
here we go so we have a bunch of events
that we can use to alert maybe off of
off of this that show that someone was
trying to run this we've been to 1604 in
our production cluster and they didn't
have all of these Atta stations that we
had defined so you can use this as a way
to alert yourself of any issues over
here we should see the push is complete
and now we have a scan that's started
and I didn't have to do anything other
than turn on the vulnerability scan API
and now all of my images are
automatically being scanned and shortly
I should see a nice report telling me
all of the scans that are in here so
once that that's complete we should get
a nice report and spinnaker is probably
already kicked off and started to check
for those vulnerabilities so it's
actually verifying that our
vulnerabilities are that we have minimal
vulnerabilities so you can see here it's
it's waiting for the vulnerability scan
to complete if we refresh should have
this complete all right so now we can
see in here a big difference from our
Alpine image the abouttwo image has a
lot more in it and we can see that there
are many TVs in here and many of them
above my CV SS threshold of 5 so
spinnaker should detect that and block
this from running so if I check out the
output again it should have waited for
it to complete it finished and now it
lists out all of the vulnerabilities
that I had and I can see that there are
many above 5.0 which was my threshold
and it's blocked my pipeline so in this
demo you've seen a CI C D pipeline with
various elements using both
vulnerability scanning and binary
authorization to lock down what
go into a production environment if we
can go back to slides here Sandra I
think yep all right you're Victor's
showed us the selections and tooling
action so what are the takeaways what
are the quick things so you can get
started and enable I am PI applying like
tonight right first you can minimize
access to your CIP pipeline get rid of
the people that really don't need access
to your CV pipeline so that you have a
minimum set of people and and and and
and if you have time or a separate
service account you use for CI from CD
so you have some segregation sex sex sex
segregation of responsibilities in your
- I have minimum minimal permissions set
up there but at least minimize the
number of people having access to your
say ICT pipeline second if you aren't
have a haven't yet use a Google managed
a secure base image you know as well as
your eyes or base image your beauty I
plan so instead of using you know Alpine
directly or one to directly using the
Google managed version of it so that it
gets automatically updated and patched
every time you push something new to
production its beaut the latest safe
version around GCR vulnerability
scanning this is the easiest one it's
really literally just one click if you
use google container registry turnout
and see all the scary vulnerability
starts filling out and telling you - of
all the bad things that are in your
image now at least you have the
information to process and potentially
act on last enforce a builder signature
with binary authorization so this is
sort of the the simplest deploy policy
that you can have make sure that the
image you deploy is actually built by
you alright so here are some additional
resources to learn more about the tools
and best practices that we talked about
today
the slides will be online at some point
after it's a presentation so you don't
have to memorize the short links and
here are some additional container
security talks and next that you can go
check out in the today and the next two
days
[Music]